[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام احييكم وهذه التاسعه
مشاهدينا نبدا بالعناوين
الاعدام ينتظروا مئه محتاج ايراني والفيفا
يطالب طهران بالكشف عن مصير اللاعب
يواجهوه نفس المصير
بعد ثلاثه اسابيع من تواعد بوتين بالرد
على الغرب موسكو تحضروا تصديرا النفط الى
الدول التي حددت سقفا للاسعار
شرب كوسوفي ينصبون مزيدا من الحواجز على
الحدود مع صربيا والغرب يحذر من تفاقم
الوضع
في امريكا ترقب لانحسار عاصفه القرن
الثلجيه وتخوف من وفاه عشرات المفقودين
تجمدا
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا سنبدا من اقليم كردستان العراق
حيث اعلن الدفاع المدني العراقي سيطرته
على الحريق الذي اندلع في ثلاثه مخازن
نفطيه في مصفى لكوير غربي اربيل في ما لم
تتضح اسباب اندلاع الحريق ولم يتم ذكر اي
تفاصيل عن وقوع خسائر بشريه على كل المزيد
ينضم الينا من الكوبرا احمد الحمداني
مراسل العربيه اهلا بك احمد انقل لنا
المشهد من عندك واخر المعلومات المتوفره
ما يسونا قف الان طبعا امام ااا مصفى الذي
تعرض للحرب وقد انهت الدفاع المدني قبل
قليل مهام في اخماد الحرائق هناك اصابتين
بين صفوف الدفاع المدني احدهما بحاله حرجه
بحسب مقام همم اربيل الذي زار الموقع مع
عده مسؤولينا للوقوف على ملابسات الحاله
لكن اسباب الحريق لم تتضع حتى الساعه وان
التحقيقات جاريه وهذا المصفى طبعا وصفه
يعود لشركات غير حكوميه وطبعا على ما يبدو
هناك قرارات بغلق ال- ال- المصفى من قبل
همم السلطات الكرديه في اقليم كردستان
ولكن قالت السلطات ان التسعه خزانات تعرضت
للحرب واتسعت همم في حريق كبير وطبعا هذه
الخزانات تستخدم لخزن الغاز السائل
تبدا المعلومات التي اوردتها السلطات
السلطات اقليم كردستان وبالتالي المكان
مغلق وقد اعيد غلقه بعد الحريق وبالتالي
لم يسمح لنا بالدخول داخل هذا الوصفه ولم
يكن هناك همم طبعا همم هناك همم فقط اشير
الى ان الاضرار او ال- الاضرار كانت بين
همم بين مشاهدات
جديده مراسل العربيه شكرا جزيلا لك على
هذه المعلومات
[موسيقى]
الى ايران الان
476 قتيلا هذا ما وصلت اليه اعداد ضحايا
الاحتجاجات في ايران مئه ظاهر على الاقل
يواجهون خطر الاعدام ارقام كشفتها منظمه
حقوقيه ايرانيه وبالحديث عن الاعدامات
كشفت ايران انترناشونال عن ان الاتحاد
الدولي لكره القدم الفيفا طلب في رساله
الى الاتحاد الايراني تقديم ايضاحات حول
مصير اللاعب السابق امير مصر ازادان وهو
معتقل ويواجه خطر الاعدام وفي اخبار
اللاعبين المؤيدين للاحتجاجات وبعد منع
عائلته من السفر قال اللاعب الايراني
السابق علي الدائري ساخرا طبعا من صواريخ
بلادي قال انه يشكر الله ان طائره عائلته
لم تصب بصواريخ طبعا في اشاره الى اطلاق
الحرس الثوري النار على طائره اوكرانيه في
يناير 20 20
وفي ضوء الاحتجاجات التي تشهدها ايران
كشفت تقارير اعلاميه كشفت ان اللاعبه
ايرانيه تدعى ساره خادم شاركت في منافسات
لبطوله الدوليه خاصه بالشطرنج اقيمت في
كازاخستان دون ارتداء الحجاب ذكرت
التقارير الاعلاميه ان اللاعب الايرانيه
لم تنشر حتى اللحظه على صفحتها في موقع
انستغرام
قبل ذلك انتحر شاب ايراني يبلغ من العمر
38 عاما في نهر الرون في مدينه اليوم جنوب
وسط فرنسا بسبب القمع الذي يتعرض له
الايرانيون منذ اشهر استنتر الشاب محمد
مرادي في مقطع فيديو نشر على انستقرام
استنكر القمع الذي يتعرض له الايرانيون
وقال انه قرر الانتحار وانه قرر ان يفعل
هذا ليظهر للجميع ان الايرانيين بحاجه الى
مساعده
وفي تقريرها السنويه حول انتهاكات السلطات
الايرانيه اكدت مجموعه نشطاء حقوق الانسان
في ايران ارانا اكدت اعدام القضاء
الايراني لاكثر من 560 شخصا من بينهم
النساء واطفال اوضحت ايضا ارتفاع تنفيذ
احكام الاعدام بنسبه
88% مقارنه بالعام الماضي لفتات تقرير
الحقوق الى ان اكثر من 18% من الاعدامات
تمت في محافظه بلوشيستان محافظات البرزه
من جهتها حلت بالمرتبه الثانيه مسجله اكثر
من 16 في المئه من هذه الاعدامات فيما
كانت اكثر الحالات في سجناي زهدان ورجائي
شهر استاند التقرير الى حوالي
13,500 تقريبا مسجل عن وضع حقوق الانسان
في ايران
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا دعونا نشاهد هذه الصور من مدينه
مهاباد الكرديه بايران حيث صرخاتم مؤلمه
لابنه المحتج الكردي كمال احمد بور الذي
قتل خلال
دعونا نتحدث عن ملف اخر ويتعلق بدعم
المتظاهرين الايرانيين سيما من النواحي
التقنيه وايضا الانترنت فقد تاكد رئيس
شركه سبايس اكس طبعا نتحدث هنا
100 محطه استقبال ارضيه لخدمات الانترنت
المؤمنه عبر شبكه ستارلينج تعمل حاليا في
ايران في اطار وعوده اي ماسك لاتاحه
الانترنت للايرانيين فما هي ستار لينك
وكيف تعمل في الداخل الايراني تحديدا
ستارلينج التي يمتلكها ماسك لديها حاليا
اكثر من
الفيء قمر اصطناعي صغير طبعا تدور حول
الارض في مدار منخفض ما يعني ان الاشارات
ستصل وبقوه اعلى الى مساحات اكثر مقارنه
طبعا بتلك التي يعطيها قمر الاتصالات
التقليديه ويتعين وجود محطات استقبال
ارضيه للاتصال بهذه الاقمار والحصول على
الانترنت وبالتالي توزيع الخدمه
للمستخدمين المحطات الارضيه تتمثل في طبق
استقبال ذات التوجيه يتم تثبيته اعلى
المنزل ويتصل بسرعه طالما ان السماء صافيه
ثم يتم توصيل بجهاز يوزع الاشاره لاسلكيا
داخل المنزل اي يطلع بدور الراوتر وفي وقت
لم يعرف بعد عدد الاجهزه الموجوده على
الاراضي الايرانيه اكد نشطاء وصول اولى
الاطباق الى داخل ايران بطبيعه الحال يتم
تهريب هذه الاجهزه حيث يعمل المهربون خاصه
في المناطق الحدوديه الكرديه على اعاده
تعبئه الاجهزه في صناديق مخصصه لافران
الميكرويف او طبعا غيرها من الادوات
المنزليه بحسب والسترتشنر للحصول على
مواقع هذه الاجهزه داخل الاراضي الايرانيه
يعتمد النظام الايراني على اجهزه مراقبه
لتحديد مواقعها لكن النشاط الايرانيين
يراقبون بشكل دائم اقتراب تلك الاجهزه
ويقومون باطفائها بين الفينه والاخرى كما
يقومون كثير مواقعها وذلك بشكل دوري
[موسيقى]
الهند
تفاصيل ومعلومات عن ماذا فعاليتها هناك
حتى نستطيع ان نعرف ماذا يمكن لنا ان
نتوقع في ايران
الاجهزه هذه الاجهزه فعاله جدا السبب في
انه يعني الارسال والاستقبال السريع جدا
ومنطقه التغطيه كبيره حتى مع وجود الطبق
الصغير هذا فهي ناجحه جدا في عمليه
المناطق اللي ما فيها انترنت ارضيه
بانها تحتاج الى الاطباق كما ذكرنا وغيرها
من الامور واللوجستيات اذا ما صحت تعبير
وبالتالي السؤال عندما يتحدث ماسك عن وجود
100 منها على الارض في ايران هل هذا كافي
ام ماذا
اخت الكريم في ثمانيه اقمار صناعيه من
ستار لينك هي الان موجوده على ايران في في
خريطه موجوده على الانترنت ممكن نشوف عدد
الاقمار على كل البلد وهذه مستمر يعني
تراقب ال- ال- المنطقه دي ف- 100 جهاز مش
كثير يعني مقارنه بالاماكن الثانيه تتكلم
على طبق صغير ما بغطي الى المنطقه بسيطه
وهو بيعطي الواي فاي اللي هي التغطيه لعدد
محدد من الناس يستقبل الانترنت
هل يمكن ان تعتبر بديل كامل بحال تم
وتوفير ما يحتاجه المحتجون او انه لا يمكن
لها ان تكون بديل ويمكن ربما تشويش عليها
من قبل النظام
اللي ما فيها موجوده همم الانترنت الارضيه
يعني اذكر لك هنا في في امريكا في مناطق
خارج المدن بيستخدموا الاطباق الاصطناعيه
على اساس انهم يستقبل الانترنت وهي كافيه
يعني الاستقبال والارسال
والمشاهده الفيديوهات واشياء كثيره فعمليه
انتشار هي عمليه فقط انه توصل هذه الاجهزه
الى الاشخاص وتركيبها سهل جدا يعني انا
باتكلم على وزن ال- ال- الصندوق نفسه
حوالي خمسه كيلوغرام بس يعني اضافه لان في
ثلاثه او اربعه قطع وتركبها مع التطبيق
وتبدا العمليه تشتغل على طول هو صحيح
دكتور ولكن بعض يقول انه قضيه تهريب هذه
همم تحتاج الى جهد كبير وايضا هناك نوع من
المراقبه الايرانيه من قبل النظام لذلك
وبالتالي البعض يقول انه شركات يمكن ان
توفر نوع اخر من الاجهزه ربما بحجم اصغر
ربما همم تكون همم ايضا سهله همم النقل
اذا مصاحب تعبير
الطابق نفسه صغير يعني تكلم على ارتفاع
النص متر او هذا مركب كامل
فعمليه انك ولما تستلمه في الصندوق لاني
ركبت عده جزء منها هنا في في سان هو زي
همم بتتكلم على انه كل قطعه لحاله
والاسلاك متوفره في السوق يعني بامكانهم
بس يحصلوا على الطبق وعلى الموزع اللي هو
الراوتر وهذه يكفيهم بقيه التوصيلات ممكن
تكون محليه ما ما يكون فيها اي نوع من
الطلب المخصوص همم من سبيس اكس او ستارت
كان معنا من سان فرانسيسكو الدكتور احمد
منافع استاذ الهندسه وامن الشبكات في
جامعه سان خوسيه شكرا جزيلا
في مدينه بوشهر الجنوبيه ايران وتابع هذه
الصور
[موسيقى]
وقع الرئيس
السوما يحضر توريد النفط والمنتجات
النفطيه للدول التي فرضت سقفا لاسعار
الخام الروسي القرار يدخل حيز التنفيذ في
الاول من فبراير شباط العام المقبل ويستمر
لمده خمسه اشهر هذا القرار ياتي بعد حوالي
ثلاثه اسابيع من توعد بوتن بالرد على
القرار الغربي بتحديد سقف لاسعار نفط
بلاده من جانبها اعلنت الخارجيه الروسيه
عن استعدادها مواصله تزويد الشركاء
بالمنتجات الدفاعيه رغم العقوبات
الامريكيه
وفي تطور قد يصعد الحرب كشف خبراء عسكريون
ان القوات الروسيه ستبدا استراتيجيه
عسكريه جديده في الحرب التي تخوضها على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه تبدا مع انتهاء فصل
الشتاء وقد تدخل فيها بيلاروسيا
الاستراتيجيه المتوقعه تتمثل في محاوله
اسقاط العاصمه كيف دعونا متابعه
ميدان المعركه الروسيه الاوكرانيه
منذ الرابع والعشرين من فبراير الماضي
ثلاث مراحل تنوعت فيها اشكال
واستراتيجيات القتال من قبل الجيش الروسي
ومرحله الرابعه على وشك البدء وفقه وبراء
المرحله الاولى هي التي تعثر فيها الجيش
الروسي في كيا
» والمرحله الثانيه هي التي تحول فيها
القتال من كتاب الى اقليم دومباز اما
المرحله الثالثه فهي استعاده اوكرانيا
لخاركيب ومدينه في جميع تلك المراحل قاتل
الجيش الروسي بالخطوط الخارجيه على جبهه
ممتده من كييف شمالا الى خرسون جنوبا
مشاكل نقص الامداد وغياب القياده الموحده
لكل جبهات
القوات الروسيه ستبدا مرحله الرابعه بعد
ذوبان ثلوج الشتاء وهدوء عواطف
ابرز ملامحها قد تكون العوده الى اسقاط
العاصمه كييف عبر بيلاروسيا مع تقييد
الهجمات الاوكرانيه في خاركه بخرسون
والتركيز على احكام السيطره على كامل
اقليم دومبرز مع محاوله استرداد الاراضي
التي يسيطر عليها الجيش الاوكراني في
الاقاليم الاربعه التي ضمها الرئيس بوتين
وخصوصا زابوريجيا
وجه جديد للمعارك قد يشهد كذلك دخوله بلا
روسيا الى المعادله خاصه ان بعض المؤشرات
تقول ان روسيا بدات ارسال قوات المدرعه
اليها مع نشر منظومه صواريخ اس 4
والصواريخ البالستيه من نوع سكندر ملوك
الشيخ العربي
برج مراقبه طوره لواء الدفاع الاقليميه
تابع للقوات الاوكرانيه بهدف مراقبه
تحركات القوات الروسيه البرج يعتمد على
مبدا مشابه لاجهزه المراقبه الامريكيه
ويحمل كاميرا بمدى خمسه كيلو مترات متابع
[موسيقى]
كيف
كاميرا فيديو
[موسيقى]
المزيد ينضم الينا من اكياس الحذيفه عادل
مراسل العربيه اهلا بك حذيفه اخر التطورات
الميدانيه
القتال يشتد في هذا المحور تركز قوات
الاتحاد الروسي جهودها الهجوميه والعسكريه
في باخ موت وفيليمان وفي اديوس كيف هذه
الثلاث محاور في دونيسك كذلك طبعا في
منطقه كوبرس والصفات حيث منطقه كريمنا
التي تحاول القوات الاوكرانيه الان
استعاده السيطره على هذه المنطقه سر
القوات الاوكرانيه قريبه من استعاده هذه
المدينه الصغيره والتي قال عنها سوف تكون
اختراق كبير لخض دفاع القوات الروسيه في
هذه المنطقه اذا طبعا بالتقدم والوصول الى
كوبر ثم بعد ذلك الى ليس الشانز همم وبعد
ذلك
وقال سقوط هذه المدينه سيخترق خط الدفاع
الاساسي في هذه الجبهه لقوات الاتحاد
الروسي طبعا القوات الروسيه تم مواصل
عمليه همم ضربات ملوخيه اطلقت 44 او نفذت
44 الضربه صاروخيه من انظمه اطلاق صواريخ
متعدده على كامل خط الجبهه كذلك عمليات
قصف جديده في اا خط اا النهر الدينيبر في
منطقه اخر سون هذه جمله لعمليات او التحرك
العمليات كذلك نفذت القوات الاوكرانيه ست
ضربات جويه في همم مراكز تمركز القوات
والمعدات همم
وانظمه الدفاع الجوي الروسيه وايضا
استطاعت ان همم تحيد همم يعني قالت انه
هنالك حوالي 100 جريح ولا ولم تحدد عدد
القتلى وعدد من القتلى من القوات الروسيه
في منطقه
حذيفه شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المعلومات
التاسعه ولكن بعد قليل
اتهامات افغانيه للامم المتحده بتجاهل
انتهاكات طالبان بحق النساء
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مجددا المزيد من التوتر على حدود
كوزوفو مع صربيا حشد عسكري صربي وتاهب
كامل للجيش على الحدود غير مباليه اي هنا
نتحدث عن صربيا للمطالب الدوليه بالضروره
ازاله تلك الحواجز تفاديا لتصعيد محتمل
بين الجانبين الامر لم يقتصر على التجاهل
الصربي بل ارتفع اكثر بقيام صرب كسوفه
بنصف بمزيد من الحواجز الجديده واغلاق
الطرق في بلده ميتروفيتسا الواقعه شمال
قفزفو علما ان البلده يتقاسمها وايضا
الالبان اجراء سبقه التعزيز الصربي على
الحدود متزامنا ايضا مع زياره لوزير
الدفاع الصربي لذات المنطقه الحدوديه
[موسيقى]
هي المره الاولى التي يغلق فيها الصلب
شوارع حتى البلدات الرئيسيه في كذب منذ
تاجيج وتاجاج الازمه حيث اقام المتظاهرون
الصلب حواجز اقامه حواجز مصنوعه من شاحنات
محمله في بلده المترو بيتزا الشماليه
البلاد كما وضعوا الحواجز على الطرق
المؤديه الى الحدود مع صربيا رغم ان
استقلال كزفو عن صربيا عمره 14 عاما الا
ان الازمه مستمره فالعاصمه بروشتينا طبعا
تواجهم معضله حقيقيه في اقناع حوالي 50000
باقي شمال البلاد باحترامي ومؤسساتها
هؤلاء يستخدمون حتى هذه اللحظه اللوحات
المعدنيه وايضا وثائق التربيه رافضين
الاعتراف بالمؤسسات التابعه لكزوفه ورغم
خطه الحكومه التي شملت اعطاء السرب على
اراضيها فتره انتقاليه للتالم الا انها
قبلت بالاحتجاجات بعد انتهاء المهله قوات
حفظ السلام بقياده نيته في كوسوفو ووصفت
الوضع الحالي في الشمال بالصعب للغايه
القوات اكدت مراقبه الموقف عن كسب مبديه
الاستعدادها للتدخل اذا ما تعرض لاستقرار
للخطر اما تركيا ف ايضا دخلت على خط
الازمه معلمنا استعدادها للوساطه وايضا
تخفيف التوتر بين البلدين تركيا اجرت
بالفعل الاتصالات منفصله مع وزيري
الخارجيه في صربيا وايضا كذوفه وداعيه
للتحلي بضبط النفس هذا وتلعب العلاقات
الوديه بين بلغراد وموسكو دور في المخاوف
الغربيه من اندلاع ازمه في المنطقه خصوصا
ان صربيا معروفه بمواقفها الايجابيه تجاه
روسيا كيف لا وهي التي قاومت وما تزال
تقاوم الضغط للانضمام الى العقوبات
الغربيه ضد موسكو
[موسيقى]
جديد جديد
والمزيد ينضم الينا الان من بشيتينا
الدكتور محمد كاليسي استاذ في الاعلام
مباحث في شؤون البلقان اهلا بك دكتور اسمح
لي ان ابدا بالصوره العامه لم يحدث الان
الى اين تتجه الامور برايك
[موسيقى]
ونحن
جدا قريبين من الموقع او من المنطقه التي
تحدث هذه الاحداث وهي الشمال
فيبدو ان الامور في هذه المرحله تتجه نحو
التصعيد سواء من الجانب الصربي بحيث يصبح
حشره قوات كبيره عن الحدود وهو كذلك نحن
الناس الان كذلك هناك تحركات جديده من
الجيش الكسوفي ولاول مره نحو الشمال
حيث سمعنا اليوم من رئيس الوزراء الكسوفي
التصريح هناك شديد اللهجه بحيث هناك كان
يحمل تهديدا ضنيا للمجتمع الدولي المتواجد
في كوسا بحيث ان لم
يتمكنوا هم بازاله الحواجز على الطرقات
المؤديه الى سوريا او بين كسرى او صربيا
فالحكومه الحوسيه لن تنتظر كثيرا وسد تتخذ
كل الخطوات اللازمه لفتح هذه الطرق
الغير مباشره حتى الان من الطرفين بحسب ما
افهم منك دكتور محمد ولكن بعض يقول انه لا
احد معني بهذا التصعيد من قبل الغرب
والاتحاد الاوروبي خاصه في ظل التطورات في
اوكرانيا الا تعتقد انه سيكون هناك دفعه
نحو التهدئه والحوار المطلوب الان بحسب
الاتحاد الاوروبي
ااا يبدو هنا
هذه الحوادث التي وضيت على الطرق القصف
جاءت بعد الازمه التي حدثت بين كتفه
وصربيا بخصوص اللوحات السيارات بحيث
الحكومه السلبيه لم تكن تعترف باللوحات
السيارات الكسوفيه ولم تكن
هناك حديث عن تاجيل تطبيق كوسوفو لقرارها
بناء على الاتفاق 2011 السؤال الان هو
الدور همم الاقليمي والدولي في التهدئه من
جهه او في اشعال ما يحدث على الارض من
مصلحه من اذا ما حدث ذلك العلاقه الروسيه
همم الصربيه هل لها ان تؤثر وهل لها ان
تفيد روسيا باي طريقه
كما هو المعروف
لدى كسفه هناك تواجد الدولي بحيث القوات
الحلف الناتو هي المسؤوله عن الامن
الخارجي للكسفه لكن يبدو ان هناك بعض
عناصر من
التي تريد من خلال هذه
او هذه الحوادث ان تضغط على الحكومه
الكوسفيه لكي هي تتنازل عن بعض القضايا
والامور فيما يتعلق بالمحادثات المستقبليه
بين كوسفى وصربيا لكن يبدو ان هناك كما
تعرفون روسيا معانيه لكن دورها ليس كبير
من جميل ج
بدول حلف الناتو ولا تستطيع ان
تفعل اي شيء دون ااا موافقه بعض العناصر
المستوى الدولي الغربي خاصه همم حتى في
الاون الاخيره نجد هناك تفهم كبير من قبل
عقوبه الولايات المتحده لمواقف صربيا في
كوبا تفهم نتفهم وعدم قدره روسيا على
الضغط ربما ممكن ان ننظر اليه ولكن قضيه
ان نصل الى مرحله الحرب او المواجهه بين
همم الجهتين من مصلحه من هل هناك من هو
معني بذلك
يبدو كل التقديرات التي
تكون
مواجهه مباشره بين الصربيا وكوسوفو لكن قد
يكون هناك نظام
يعني محدود النطاق في شمال
نحن نرى الحكومه يوسف هي التي معنيه جدا
ان تزيل هذه الحواجز لانها هي تعتبر الضغط
عليها للتنازل خاصه فيما يتعندك بخصوص
اتحاد البلديات السلبيه في كسوفان
كان معنا من بريشتينا عاصمه كوسوفو
الدكتور محمد كاليسي استاذ في الاعلام
وباحث في شؤون البلقان شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
تتواصل ردود الفعل المهدده بقيود طالبان
ضد النساء الا ان الانتقاد هذه المره جاء
للطرف اخر انتقدت سفيره الحكومه الافغانيه
السابقه لدى النمسا مونيزا بختري مسؤولي
بعثه الامم المتحده في افغانستان وقالت ان
مسؤوليه بعثت الامم المتحده في افغانستان
يحاولون تبييض صفحه طالبان وتطبيع
العلاقات معها من خلال تظليل الراي العام
العالمي كما اتهمت البعثه الاميه بالوقوف
ضد الشعب الافغاني بتقديم تقارير غير
عادله تتجاهل الانتهاكات الجسيمه لحقوق
الانسان
ومن جانبها دانت مفوضيه حقوق الانسان في
الامم المتحده زياده القيود على حقوق
المراه في افغانستان قال مفوض وحقوق
الانسان انه لا يمكن لدوله ان تتطور او
تبقى على الصعيد الاجتماعي والاقتصادي مع
استبعاد نصف سكانها اشار الى ان القيود
التي فرضتها طالبان ضد النساء لا يمكن
استيعابها وستؤدي الى زياده معاناه جميع
الافغان وستشكل خطرا خارج حدود افغانستان
المسؤول الامميه اضافه ايضا ان حضر عمل
النساء في المنظمات غير الحكوميه
سيحرمهن ويحرم الاسر من الدخل ومن حق
الاسهامي بايجابيه في تنميه البلاد
هذا هو نظام المزيد من منظمات الاغاثه الى
قرار تعليقي عملها في افغانستان اعتراضا
على قرار طالبان منعاه الاف السيدات من
العمل في القطاع خاصه في ظل مخاوف اي
يواجه 38 مليون شخص الجوع في افغانستان
جراء هذا التعطيل القائمه بالاعمال
الامريكيه في افغانستان حذرت من ان قرار
طالبان سيؤدي الى المجاعه وجاء في بيان
المشترك صادر عن منظمات انقذوا الاطفال
والمجلس النرويجي للاجئين وكير انه سيتم
تعليقه برامج الاغاثه بانتظار اتضاح
الصوره بشكل او بشان هذا الاعلان
[موسيقى]
في تسعه ولكن بعد قليل
تجاه الصين
[موسيقى]
التي وصفت بالاسوا في تاريخ الولايات
المتحده يتوقع الليله بدايه لانحسار
العاصفه التي وصفت ايضا بعاصفه القرن لقيا
ما لا يقل عن 56 شخصا مصر حتى هذه اللحظه
فيما تتخوف فرق الانقاذ من وفاه عشرات
المفقودين نتيجه التجمد بعد الحصار حصار
العاصفه من بين الوفيات 28 شخصا في غرب
ولايه نيويورك وحدها معظمهم في مدينه
بافلو التي شهدت انهيارا في الخدمات بسبب
العاصفه اكد مسؤول بالولايه ان بعض
الاشخاص حصروا في سياراتهم لاكثر من يومين
كما عجزت العديد من سيارات الطوارئ عن
الوصول الى المناطق الاكثر تضررا لمساعده
السكر
[موسيقى]
عظمه وسعه النطاق تسيطر على الولايات
المتحده طبعا مع استمرار العاصفه غير
المسبوقه ظروف شتاء قاسيه وثلوج ايضا
شخصا على الاقل حتى هذه اللحظه تركت عشرات
الالاف من المنازل دون كهرباء ودونا مياه
في مدن متفرقه مثلا الواقع غرب نيويوركيا
واحده من اكثر المدن المتضرره من هذه
العاصفه الثلجيه التي اطلق عليها عاصفه
القرن الالاف من سكانها تقطعت بهم السبل
فيما عالق اخرون في منازل مغطاه بان
جرافات شديده العلوم قدرات بسته اقدام
طبعا هذه العاصفه التي اخذت سماء الولايات
المتحده من الطائرات وايضا عطلت الالاف من
الرحلات الداخليه وايضا الدوليه فتحت
النقاش مجددا حول التغير المناخي وحول
دوره في حدوث الظواهر المناخيه القصوى
نطاق العاصفه غير مسبوق تقريبا امتد من
منطقه البحيرات العظمى قرب كندا الى ريو
غراندي على طول الحدود مع المكسيك بحسب
خبراء فان التغير المناخي يسرع من وتيره
حدوث العوامل المناخيه المتشدده المحذرين
من ان الامر لا يقتصر على شتاء قارس او
عواصف وفيضانات بل ستزيد هذه العوامل في
كل فصول السنه ما يشمله ذلك من حدوث على
سبيل المثال حرائق وايضا جفاف اضافه طبعا
الى الفيضانات والعواصف اكد خبراء ان
وتيره حصول مثل هذه العواصف كانت كل خمس
سنوات في السابق لكن التغيرات المناخيه
المتسارعه قد تؤدي لحدوثها مره او مرتين
خلال العام واحد
[موسيقى]
قمر تطوير التكنولوجي للصين اولا هو اكثر
ما يشغل اداره جو بايد ان تجاه الصين
حاليا سياسه لن تكون اخاف من سياسه سلفه
دونالد ترامب بل ربما اشد وفقا لبلاتيكو
الامريكيه البيت الابيض
لفرد تغيير جذر للعلاقه الاقتصاديه
الامريكيه مع ثاني اكبر قوه اقتصاديه في
العالم اكثر التغيرات شده بعد الرسوم
الجمركيه هي توسيع القيود على الشحنات
الامريكيه الى الصين من اشباه الموصلات
المستخدمه في الذكاء الاصطناعي وادوات
صناعه الرقائق
[موسيقى]
طبعا مشاهدينا الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه
للجديده ستعمل على الحد من التطور
التكنولوجي للصين الذي يخالف عقودا من
السياسه الفيدراليه و يمثل اجراء اداره
بيض حاليا الاكثر عدوانيه حتى الان لي
تقليس تكنولوجيا الاقتصاد والعسكر اللي
بكين وذلك وفقا لمسؤولينا امريكيين
القواعد الفيدراليه الجديده والاوامر
التنفيذيه والتشريعات المتعلقه التي
تستهدف قطاعات التكنولوجيا الفائقه في
الصين والتي بدات هذا العام وستمر في 20
23 هي تتويج للسنوات
التي ساعدت في تصميم السياسه الاقتصاديه
لاداره ترامب قالتليتكو ان يعتبر الابتكار
المحلي الصيني تهديد للامن القومي في حد
ذاته طبعا هذه هي قفزه كبيره من ما كانت
عليها امريكا من قبل ك الاستراتيجيه
الجديده التي تسميها اداره بايدن داخليا
بجانده الحمايه ستكون قادره على وقف قدره
الشركات الصينيه على تصنيع الرقائق
الالكترونيه المتقدمه سيتبع ذلك قريبا امر
تنفيذي بانشاء سلطه فدراليه جديده لتنظيم
الاستثمارات الامريكيه في الصين سيما
القطاع الالكتروني اضافه طبعا الى عدم
تخفيف القيود الجمركيه الامريكيه المفروضه
اصلا على التجاره الصينيه وذلك منذ عهد
دونالد ترامب
[موسيقى]
المزيد ينضم الينا من بكين الصحفي نادر
رونج اهلا بك سيد نادر اسمحلي ان ابدا
بقراءه في الصين كيف تنظر الى مثل هذه
التقارير وما ينقل عن استراتيجيه جديده في
التعاطي مع التكنولوجيا الصينيه من قبل
الولايات المتحده
اهلا ومرحبا بكم
اولا يعني
مثل هذه السياسات الامريكيه وترى ان هذا
هذه السياسات هي فعلا سياسه حمائيه
بشكل احادي وكذا وهذا
يخالف هذا يخالف قواعد النظام تجاره همم
نتيجه النظام تجاري المتعدد الاتراك وكذلك
القواعد ثم نظمت تجاره العالميه وكذلك
سيؤثر سلبا على سلاسل توريد همم في العالم
في هذا القطاع فلذلك تحوث ولايه المتحده
بعد عدم تاسيس التجاره همم
[موسيقى]
حمايه الدفاع عن تجاره حره همم التي كانت
الولايات المتحده قائدا لها
على ذلك ولكن اذا لم تستمع الاداره
الامريكيه لهذه المطالب الصينيه ما هي
الاوراق التي يمكن ان تستخدمها ذكرت منظمه
التجاره العالميه وغيرها هل الصين ستتجه
الى المنظمات الدوليه الى المسلك القانوني
الدولي اذا ما صح التعبير او لا هناك طرق
اخرى
همم
ولكن يبدوا همم الولايات المتحده تجاهلت
قرارات المناظمه التجاره العالميه ويعني
ترفضوا تنفيذ حكم
المناظمه التجاره العالميه همم
تدافع عن حقوقها من خلال وسائل قانونيه
والقواعد او همم
قوانين دوليه
ثم اذا لم تنافس الولايات المتحده تنفيذ
قوات يعني قانون الدولي بس همم تعتمد على
نفسه اللي همم الاستثمار وتدوير في هذا
القطاع همم المحاولات همم يعني
التكنولوجيا همم ستلاقى بالفشل الى شكلها
ههه
ولكن نحن الان نتحدث عن توجه جديد
استراتيجي للولايات المتحده تقول ان الصين
ستستمر في استخدام اوراقها في المنظمات
الدوليه وان الولايات المتحده اذا ما
اكملت ما تريد لن تنجح على اي اساس تعتمد
الصين على ماذا تعول بهذا الاطار
او في المناظمه التجاره العالميه الثانيه
ايضا تستثمر في هذا المجال
والابداع في مجال همم الانتاج
وكذلك اشباه المواصلات مواصلات
كما اا ال- الشهاده هناك تقدم كبير في
مجال الفضاء رغم كل الضغوط همم عرفت
التعاون من قبل الولايات المتحده اعتقده
في هذا همم
من بكين الصحفي نادي الروم شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
نبقى في الصين اذا تشهد واكلات السياحه
والاسفار اقفالا واسعا من طرف المواطنين
قبيل اعاده فتح حدود البلاد بعد ان قررت
الحكومه الغاء القيود المرتبطه بفايروس
كورونا في وقت تواصل البلاد تسجيلات
مستويات قياسيه في عدد الاصابات التي تخطت
عتبه المليون اصابه في اليوم في بعض
المناطق
السفر
انتظره الملايين من الصينيين تحديدا ثلاث
سنوات صعبه وطويله مرت بها البلاد التي
كانت بؤره للواء الذي غير مجرى حياتهم
وحياته العالم باسره بعض اسابيع فقط من
تخلي بكين عن سياستها الصارمه لاحتواء
الوباء والتي صاحبها تسجيل معدلات قياسيه
في الاصابات اجراء جديد تم اتخاذه في خطوه
ايضا لامتصاص الاستياء الشعبي من
الاغلاقات تمثل برفع قيود السفر والتنازل
عن الاختبار والحجر الصحي للمسافرين خصوصا
الوافدين
بطريقه علميه
لا مزيد من الاجراءات المرهقه لكل
المسافرين والوافدين للصين فشركات السياحه
والسفر وبمجرد اعلان الحكومه عن هذا
القرار عرفت اقبالا كبيلا قبيل اعاده فتح
حدود البلاد في الثامن من يناير للعام
المقبل
لقد كنت متحمسا للغايه عندما سمعت الخبر
كان غير متوقع كنت اتطلع اليها كنت اسافر
كثيرا وانا متعطش
للسفارهم لسنوات لذلك ستكون هناك زياده
هائله في عدد الاشخاص المسافرين
على مواقع السفر واظهرت بياناته منصه
السفر تضعف عمليات البحث عن وجهات السفر
في غضون نصف ساعه فقط من تداول خبر رفع
قيود الحجر الصحي وتصدر تايلاند واليابان
وكوريا الجنوبيه الوجهات
الثمن من يناير من مقبل يمثل خطوه حاسمه
لاعاده فتح الصين امام العالم وهنا سيتمكن
القاده الاجانب مره اخرى من السفر الى
بكين دون ان ينحصر في فقاعه صحيه خطوه
كبيره اتخذتها الحكومه الصينيه لاحتواء
الاستياء الشعبي وبحث السياحه من جديد
وايضا لتدارك الاضرار الاقتصاديه المستمره
منذ العام 2020 والتي تسببت في ركود لم
يسبق له مثيل في الاقتصاد الصيني
[موسيقى]
ما عكس ارتفاع اسعار العملات الاجنبيه
وتقييد البنوك المصريه لاستخدامات بطاقات
الائتمان بالخارج ستنخفض اعداد المصريين
المسافرين الى الخارج رنده ابو العزم مع
التفاصيل
عندما سافر جوليا لدراسه الكمبيوتر
والهندسه في هولندا لم تتوقع ان تواجه هي
واسرتها صعوبه في التحويل والتوفير العمله
الاجنبيه لتواجه جوليا مشاكل يوميه منذ
سته اشهر اثناء دراستها في هولندا
وانا قلت الاهلي
في مصر من شهر ثلاثه تقريبا او من عبدات
الحرب الالكترونيه الروسيه
فالناس اريد عارفه عارفه ان اولادي في
مشاكل في الدولار وفي مشاكل في العمله
وتوفير العمله الصعبه ايا كانت نوعها
فدلوقتي العدد احنا ممكن نقول ان هو قال
لي بنسبه 50% اللي هو الناس اللي بتقدم
عشان تدرس بره ومع صعوبه تدبير العمله
الاجنبيه وفي ظل وجود سوق موازين او ما
يطلق عليه السوق السوداء فرضت البنوك
العامله في مصر قيودا مؤخرا على استخدامي
بطاقات الائتمان وخفضت حدود السحب النقدي
والشراء من الخارج بعد رصد ممارسات خاطئه
باستخدام كروت لمواطنين مقيمين في مصر لم
يغادروها في اعمال تجاريه وشراء الذهب
والسحب الدولار من الخارج
شركات السياحه كانت بتحجز همم رحلاتها
بطاقات الائتمان فهي بتمارس عمل تجاري من
خلال اداه استخدام شخصي فهنا فيه سوء
استخدام
غير انخفاض سعر الجنيه مقابل ارتفاع اسعار
العملات الاجنبيه قد يكون عامله جذب
للسائح الاجنبي
هل ده يؤثر على عدد السائحين الوافدين او
كذا قلت لا مش قبل 7 اشهر
اعداد المصريين المسافرين للخارج خاصه
للسياحه فضلا عن التاثير سلبا على سفر
المواطنين للعلاج اه الدراسه راندا ابو
العزم العربيه القاهره
شهدت عدد من المحافظات العمانيه ومنها
العاصمه مسقط هطول امطار متفاوته الغزاره
بدايه من صباح اليوم ما ادى لتعليق
الدراسه في العاصمه
[تصفيق]
ومن عمان الى تبوك شمال غرب السعوديه التي
تضرب موعد سنويا مع الثلوج نشاهد هذه
الصور من تساقط الثلوج على جبل اللوز
[موسيقى]
في الكويت شهاده البلاد تساقط البرد في
عدد من المناطق العلامه من ابرزها منطقه
ميناء الشعيبه في العاصمه
وادي وقفه مع ابرز احداث اغسطس لهذا العام
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
دفاع
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
مواضيع التعاون
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الى العناوين
الاعدام ينتظر ايراني والفيفا يطالب طهران
بالكشف عن مصيري لاعب يواجه المصير نفسه
الى الدول التي حددت سقفا للاسعار
شرب كوسوفو ينصبون مزيدا من الحواجز على
الحدود مع صربيا ولا غرب يحذر من تفاقم
الوضع
في امريكا ترقب لانحسار عاصفه القرن
الثلجيه وتخوف من وفاه عشرات المخطوطين
تجمد
التاسعه انتهت ولكن الاخبار مستمره مع 360
وطاهر
شكرا لك ميسون راح تقدري تكوني معنا اليوم
كمان
شكرا كثير موضوع الايراني بشقيه النووي
وكذلك التظاهرات في الداخل اضافه الى
توقعات مدفادف الصادمه لما سيحصل في
العالم نناقشها مع استاذ الاعلام